hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round seven of the
23rd european team championship so many
of you guys have already requested it
and for very good reasons uh it's
saliresa perugia versus the master of
the mystic hearts abadujobava who on a
on a bad day you know plays incredible
chess on a good day he just uh you know
creates uh masterpieces uh you know
whenever he touches chess pieces so it's
a very exciting match and uh you know
when job is playing the game is never a
boring one so uh without further ado
let's check it out that there's quite a
lot to enjoy uh alireza with the white
pieces opens with e4 and the very
interesting thing about the match um is
that of course it's france versus
georgia that the other three boards have
already drawn their game very very early
on so this game is not only about who
will win between the two of them but
also who wins this game wins the match
for their team so you know something
else to add uh we have c6 job goes for
the karo khan defense d4 d5 and now e5
advancing the pawn we have bishop to f5
and now knight to f3 so the advanced
variation uh um
shorts uh a short line of the advanced
variation of the carl khan we have e6
and now bishop to e2 uh we have knight
to e7 and here yeah it is just castles
and now h6 so preparing to bring the
bishop back to h7 so you can uh shift
this knight to f5 or usually if white
develops the bishop to d3 then you don't
care if white traits you're going to
have an excellent outpost for your
knight on f5
we have knight beat to d2 and now knight
to d7 so black uh still waiting with
this c5 maneuver so knight to b3 for the
moment alireza controls that c5 square
and the bishop back to h7 uh joe bava
frees up the f5 square for the knight
with a4 a very nice expansion on the
queen side uh also a5 a6 might be an
idea in the future so black plays a6 and
now bishop to d2 so still uh waiting to
decide what will happen in the center
the black king is still in the center of
the board whether we're gonna have a c5
or
something else
remains to be seen but it's a car con so
you know we should be expecting um a
move like c5 and here
knight to g6 is a move that's uh you
usually played here but here we have
queen to c7 a very rare move uh which
already counters with rook to c1 makes
sense you want to develop the rook the
queen is on c7 so why not if the if the
c file opens up uh that should be good
for us and now there there are a couple
of games where knight to c8 was played
but here we have rook to d8 by jobama uh
and it is now uh uh only as of move 11
that we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how alireza continues here so
as he played rook to c11 might expect a
c4 here but he decides to go for bishop
to a5 attacks the queen and the rook
and you have to play b6 your knight to
b6 just looks weird that night is never
you know getting out of there you will
not be able to un-pin so b6 bishop back
to b4 and now even a5 uh further further
chasing the bishop uh also interesting
is maybe just knight to f5 because
bishop to d6 is the idea here so you
could maybe play something like knight
to f5 or for a trade here uh but this is
also fine for uh for white uh for
example bishop captures knight captures
and we capture on a6 we win a pawn uh
and we have a a very nice position so
you have to be careful not to blunder
that a6 pawn so a5 also one of the
reasons why juba decided to push it we
have bishop to d6 now attacking the
queen queen to b7 and now continuing
development with queen to d2 uh we have
knight the c8 now trying to chase away
the bishop and all it is just captures
with bishop captures and f8 knight
captures and now knight the e1
as of course you are expecting c5 we
have to strengthen our center with a
move like f4 but also it might also be
possible to push that pawn even further
if the white king blacking decides to
remain in the center of the board
and here we have knight to e7 uh you
could also try something like knight to
d7 try and undermine this spawn for
example we're going to play c5 undermine
the center and then this pawn maybe
becomes weak uh then maybe something
like f4 and then if castles uh it's a
very interesting position but maybe
white could even start attacking with a
move like g4 so jobama tries something
else he goes for knight to e7 and now we
have knight to d3 still with very nice
control of the c5 square and knight to
d7 now uh we have knight to f4 by
alireza uh so the the f4 pawn remains uh
on f2 for the moment we have castles and
now we have rook f to e1 so it doesn't
seem uh like the df pawn will be pushed
all the way to f4 we have rook to c8
still waiting with c5 najaba wants to
play rook to c7 bring the other rook
over to c8 and only then execute c5 we
have c3 strengthening the center here
and rook to c7 continuing uh with this
plan but now alireza could you know play
a variety of moves here he decides to go
for the absolute sharpest line and that
is g4 it's hard to say if this is even a
line if this is even good but it allows
a white for some very very uh dynamic
play
so how do you continue here well the
thing is if you just continue rook f to
c8 we can play g5 this is our main goal
and for example h captures knight h5
we're attacking the g five point we're
going to have a lot of pressure on
black's king side so white white will
enjoy this position very much so instead
after g4 we have queen to b8 by jobaba
and this means that uh well just pushing
g5 now might not be all that impressive
if we push g5 now we could actually
capture here and after knight h5 even
play f6 uh point is after let's say pawn
captures we're going to play knight
captures queen captures on g5 there's
knight captures on g5 and after bishop
captures there's this rook to f5 very
annoying move attacking the queen the
queen has to keep an eye on the bishop
then our queen can come to f8 so that's
why the queen to b8
is annoying against this g5 line so
instead after this queen to b8 move
alireza plays queen to e3
uh and now we have queen to d8 uh so
just
uh preparing to bring the queen closer
to the to the uh king side uh also
interesting was uh maybe a move like b5
but uh you know it's so hard to decide
to play such a move all the action is on
the king side and you know to play
something like this is like saying yeah
nothing is happening on the king side
let's just you know put some pressure
here you you pressure this pawn and if a
captures you're going to play a4 attack
the knight and after the knight moves
you can play c captures on b5 saying
that you don't really have anything on
the king's side uh but you know yeah
it's hard to do to play uh just like
that queen to d8 is played
and now we have h3h4 probably also a
possibility but alireza does not want to
over push anything
we have king to h8 getting the king to a
little bit of a safer square and now
knight to d2 now the knight can come for
example maybe to f3 maybe to h4 maybe to
g5 in the future all depends on what
black plays
and finally we have c5 so now black
decides to play on the queen side or
rather uh you know against the whites uh
strong center we have bishop to b5 as
the square has now been uh freed up and
now knight to c6 we have king to h2
alireza also improves the position of
his king uh and now we have c captures
on d4 uh so this is a maybe a a and too
early of a trade in the center maybe
something like queen to e7 followed by
rook after c8 doubling up on the c file
uh preparing this and then maybe we'd
have more pressure on the c file so
maybe it's uh you know no no rush
capturing on d4 but he goes for it we
have c captures on d4 c captures and now
knight to b4 now offering a trade of
rooks uh which alireza goes for we have
rook captures queen captures and now
queen to c3 he offers a queen trade uh
but it's the one
that you know black's not too eager to
to accept because if if this is traded
where do you put the knight for example
you could place knight to c2 attack the
rook uh because our knight on d7 is
hanging so you have to play everything
with tempo and after some like rook to
d1 we're going to play knight to b8 and
then for example knight b1 taking away
the a3 square from from this knight here
it's uh you know uh a difficult position
at best for black so uh joba tries
something else he doubles up on the c
file and alireza also doubles up on the
c file but now trading is no longer an
option because we really needed that
rook to be an e1 for this to work if now
if you trade now we just trade
everything just captures captures and
now uh you will lose one of the
one of the knights there's you know no
playing this so instead after rook the
c1 and we have the only move that black
has in the position that doesn't uh you
know put him in in a really bad spot and
that is bishop to c2 uh you know
if there's nothing else you will find
such a move and this is what job plays
and now uh you you're just threatening
queen captures on c3 so while you could
trade with queen captures and c7 alireza
decides no no no there's no reason to
trade let's play queen g3 we still want
to push g5 attack on the king side and
for the moment you can't move your
bishop the queen is in c7 uh so here we
have queen back to d8 and another
interesting position where
uh black probably could have played a
little bit better uh is that uh well uh
i'm just gonna show you why uh knight to
f8 is the movie you have to play because
now after g5 h captures and g5 and queen
captures you can play queen to d8 now
and now you offer a queen trade and of
course after white declines this you can
play kink the g king j8 and after rook
to g1 you can play bishop to f5 and
there's no breaking through this if you
try something like knight f3 to bring
another attacker into the game just rook
c2 and black is perfectly fine here you
know no danger here whatsoever however
after the move in the game queen to d8
it seems like it's uh you know
the same even better because we guard
the g the g5 square
right away uh it does allow alireza a
very very tricky maneuver and that's
just removing uh the queen from the
defense of the g5 square so here we have
bishop captures on d7 as you might have
expected uh queen captures on d7 and now
g5 so now we are breaking through and
the situation on the clock is very
interesting it's uh some 18 minutes for
both of them it's moved 34 they still
have to make six more moves to reach
time control so here h captures on g5 we
have queen captures and now queen to d8
this is a must play
move because if you play anything else
here for example knight to d3 uh let's
play any move just to show you the
threat rook to g1 and there's no
defending the position now whatever you
play let's say rook j8 we're gonna
you're gonna get checkmated so it's a a
very very tricky position so queen to d8
has to be played you do not want to give
alireza any free moves with the queen so
now we're offering a queen trade and we
have queen to h5 with check we have king
to g8 and now
uh alireza has to figure out how to how
to go about this because he's um
uh well it's still not very easy and the
time is running low so here we have
knight to f3 of course we want to play
knight g5 and then put some pressure on
black's position
and here g6 this is the absolute best
defense for black and it's uh one that's
not um
you know uh
easily circumvented so here we have rook
to g1 uh
spent a lot of time on this move he
spent some seven minutes which is a lot
since he had like 14. uh but there was
um
there was some talk of queen to h6
because we really want to play knight to
g5 here we can't play knight to g5
because our queen would be hanging so
that's why it is a played rook to g1
first to pin the g pawn but queen h6 is
also very interesting then we have to
play queen f8 queen back to h4 and now
we are again preparing this knight to g5
of course rook also is coming to g1 but
now now if queen 28 are offering another
trade now queen g5 knight g5 is just
winning so black would really have to
figure out something else here probably
queen to g7 but it's very similar to
what happened in the actual game so in
the game rook the g1 was played now
comes knight to c6 and um
it's interesting this is move 38 so
jobaba played this very quickly alireza
was extremely low on time uh but uh to
play this to absolute perfection with
black you have to play king to f8 but
maybe if he invested a little bit more
time he would have found it but he
thought that maybe
it would best it'd be best to just play
uh you know really quickly how it is i
was low on time but the the point is
after this move uh for example if we
play some like queen h7 we're going to
play king to e8 and now after queen to
g8 to check king to e7 we can play queen
to g7 and after queen to h8 offering a
trade we can play this knight capture
son g6 maneuver because the f pawn is
pinned for example bishop captures on g6
we can play rook captures on g6 and now
let's say the queens get traded off uh
yes you are down upon but your position
is very much playable it's very unlikely
that white will be able to win this so
that's the way to go however he tried
playing uh against alireza's time uh so
he played knight to c6 but now uh
alireza has to find uh uh how to
continue this game he played queen to h6
and th this is not an easy decision to
make because knight captures on g6 just
looks so good
that it must be winning but it's not i'm
going to show you why it's not the
problem with knight captures on g6 f
captures rook captures with check bishop
captures queen captures on g6 with check
of course you can't go to f8 if you go
to faded the knights the g5 is just
winning checkmate is being threatened
and if you prevent this knight captures
an e6 check black has no moves you have
to give up the queen uh but still you
could play king to h8 and now you know
knight to g5 doesn't really do all that
much rook the c7 prevents checkmate and
after queen h6 checking g8 queen
captures an e6 check king to f8 and
there's no way uh for white to finish
the attack you're gonna have to settle
for some sort of a perpetual with uh
with a repetition of queen h6 queen to
e6 uh so this is best for for uh obama
uh uh but um uh uh
not for job this would be best but uh
you know
not uh not for more than a draw so here
queen to h6 of course you want to keep
all of your options open and uh well one
more move to time control so nothing to
worry about
we have queen to f8 offering a queen
trade and now queen to h4 alireza played
this with like 20 seconds on the clock
so he of course he timed it perfectly he
wanted to check all of his options uh
and then he played it and now he was uh
awarded additional time so we we don't
have to rush anymore we have queen to g7
and now comes a move that well it has a
hat to check before playing but of
course everything is on the the g file
uh knight to h5 so we're really going
after that f6 square
and here
what do you play well queen to h8 is a
move you have to play again really
really complicated position because now
after knight to f6 check we can play
king to g7 and now after queen to g5 we
can play bishop to f5 that's the point
and now after knights to g4 uh we
started running away with the king king
the
uh king the f eight king to e8 king to e
uh d7 and and so on so this is what uh
black should go for however queen to h6
was played and this allows alireza to
play a beautiful beautiful maneuver
so feel free to pause the video and try
to figure out the absolute best and only
winning attempt for white while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
well brilliant idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show uh it is
rook the g4
that's the good stuff uh you know
delivering check or trying something for
example checking g7 doesn't really do
anything and if you try something like
knight to g5 it looks it looks very
impressive impressive but there's queen
captures on h5 that's the problem queen
captures g captures and you don't have
any uh reasonable discoveries here you
can grab one pawn deliver a check from
the rook once the king moves that's it
you're done material you're completely
lost however the move that alireza
played rook to g4 that's just uh you
know
such a spectacular move that really
leaves black hopeless uh the thing is if
uh for example just to give you uh an
example uh if you play something like
bishop f5 attack this weirdly place the
rook on g4 now we play knight to f6
check and after king to g7 we very
happily trade queens that's the that's
the point king captures and now comes
rook to h for check and now you can see
that the knight here covers all of this
and this was the idea rook to g4 to h4
and now we see a very quick win for
white rook h7 checking a fade rookie
cha-cha king to e7 and we pick up the
rook here uh and that's it uh or you
know anything else if king goes back we
still pick up the rook doesn't really
matter so that's the the the idea behind
rook to g4 yeah so in the game job play
king to f8 it is the absolute most
resilient defense and now queen to f6
not allowing this captures because the
queen here is hanging and again
not not a lot of moves here uh to to
play for black so you could attempt
queen captures on h5 but then rook to h4
and you have to give up the queen now
because rook to h8 will be checkmate
or you could try something like king
back to g8 which is also a very
interesting idea but now comes knight to
g5 and this is just incredible now the
the f7 pawn is hanging we have to play
something let's say rook rook to f8
defending this now queen to f4 and again
it's uh such a difficult position to
handle for black uh you're gonna have to
go for this queen captures an h5
maneuver now rook h4 and you have to
uh you know play something you either
give up the queen here or you keep the
queen with something like this but then
queen f6 and there's no defending
checkmate now you have to give up the
queen once again so whatever whatever
black does black will have to part with
the queen at some point but uh jobala
still tries to keep everything intact we
have knight to d8 adding a defender to
the f7 pawn also to the e6 pawn and now
comes rook to h4 just mounting the
pressure little by little uh we have
king to g8 uh and now comes uh well now
comes knight to g5 and look at this all
of these pieces in front of the black
king i mean this um this is uh this is
something you will see in the book uh
you know uh you know a hundred year old
book uh about tactics so that's uh
that's um uh what this uh you know it
looks to me like and here again the only
way to play this is to give up the queen
but it's insufficient if you play queen
captures on h5 we're going to play rook
captures g captures but the problem is
there's knight captures on f7 and you
know black will have some compensation
for the queen uh for example the rook is
attack rook to c7 we can pick up the b6
pawn but it's just not enough this is
going to fall we have a past e pawn
black king is wide open we're easily
going to win this so instead after
knight to g5 jobama played bishop to d1
he said all right i might be interested
in capturing this knight with the bishop
but now he gives alireza a chance to
finish this game with another brilliancy
so feel free to pause the video and try
to spot this brilliancy while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea there are some other
winning moves here for example like f3
we just prevent the bishop from
attacking the knight but that would be
way way uh slow playing this uh but if
you found the move alireza played then
really congratulations you are uh really
uh
well a true master of the dark arts so
here queen captures on the e8 was played
a check was delivered and he was in this
position on move 46 that badur jobaba
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so the thing is now you are in check you
have to capture this or you know block
with the queen but that also doesn't
work if you block with the queen it's
just a very nice knight to f6 checking
the g7 and rook to h7 checkmate
so that's not going to work so we're
going to have to capture the queen and
now it's a you know just knight f6
checking g7 we're going to capture the
queen here but even that doesn't help
just captures we're going to deliver
this check uh fork the king and the rook
after the king moves we're going to pick
up the rook and yes you can pick up this
pawn maybe say you have some counter
play but not really knight captures here
with check king f7 we're gonna play
knight g5 check and once the king moves
we're gonna capture this pawn as well
and that there is no playing this of
course we're up a piece we have too much
uh you know we have too much in the
position
uh so after this beautiful uh temporary
queen sacrifice uh jubav resigned the
game and another brilliant victory for
uh alireza who is now uh this close to
2800 he is uh
interestingly he is only uh 0. 0.1 uh
point uh
behind the ding on the live ratings list
uh but you know as the ratings you don't
have decimal spots uh you know they're
going to round it up he's going to have
the exact same rating as ding but uh
fides says that as ding played less
games than alireza this year this would
also mean that alireza will be number
two but that's only if he stops playing
the tournament now there are still two
more rounds in this tournament so he's
either gonna go up or down we'll see
will he be able to clinch that 2800 in
this tournament or will uh you know
something else happen uh but yeah uh
that's uh the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh not only did alireza win this
brilliancy and you know he comes this
close to you know reaching that 2800
barrier becoming the youngest person
ever to achieve this but also he won the
match for his team so france defeated
georgia here as like we said in the
beginning the other three boards that
drew their games very early on and it
was all about this board whoever wins it
wins the entire match
so there you have it uh wins the game
wins the match this close to 2800 what
will happen we will see two morons to go
you know uh sorry about so many already
games but i'm just very very excited you
know about all of this happening you
know aside from the world chess
championship now uh this uh you know
onslaught by by the young gentleman here
is is very very impressive and you know
i intend to show uh you know
as much as he's he's intending to show
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to zuza and i would like
to uh thank michael kennedy constantinos
on fridays uh rod hill and tudor sharp
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it uh as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this a wonderful event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day